[Musique]
aujourd'hui, nous avons uni nos forces avec nos
homologues ukrainiens parce qu'il est
en fait très important de soutenir
l'Ukraine et de soutenir la
Biélorussie démocratique parce que nous luttons pour une
chose importante pour la démocratie.
[Musique]
le premier hub international de startups en
exil, donc malheureusement, le gouvernement
consacre le régime  et les batteries
n'ont pas besoin L'innovation n'a pas besoin Les
entrepreneurs n'ont pas besoin d'investissements,
nous sommes donc obligés de fermer notre
entreprise en Biélorussie et de suivre les
innovateurs de nos startups Odin en exil et de
les soutenir ici en Europe
[Musique]
en fait, je le ferais  disons que des centaines de milliers
d'entrepreneurs ont dû déménager de
Biélorussie
après la crise politique de 2020, ils ont
d'abord été affectés à l'Ukraine et
après les 24 et 22 février, en fait, l'
année dernière, ils ont dû déménager d'Ukraine,
donc nous avons tout pour la première
fois, première double relégation  première
licorne en exil, d'ailleurs premier
hub de startup en exil
étranger
[Musique]
nous avons commencé comme une initiative technologique en tant que
hub de startup mais nous sommes obligés de
nous impliquer dans la résolution de la crise politique,
j'espère que nous changerons un
jour notre pays pour le mieux.  moi-même, je fais
partie du Conseil de coordination, chef des
Affaires étrangères au
Conseil de coordination de Biélorussie, si profondément impliqué
dans la situation politique
[Musique],
nous venons de prouver notre solidarité avec les
Ukrainiens à travers un certain nombre d'
initiatives aidant également les Ukrainiens à
quitter l'Ukraine pour trouver leur
foyer  en Europe pour soutenir la
résilience du peuple ukrainien,
nous investissons dans les
startups ukrainiennes en investissant dans zilli, l'
une des startups ukrainiennes prometteuses que nous
sommes, nous fournissons tout gratuitement
aux Ukrainiens chez imoguru, y compris les
espaces de co-working, le mentorat, le
réseautage, etc.